let's say we have the relationship Y is
equal to cosine of 5x minus 3y and what
I want to find is the rate at which Y is
changing with respect to X and we'll
assume that Y is a function of X so
let's do what we've always been doing
let's apply the derivative operator to
both sides to both sides of this
equation on the left hand side right
over here we get dy/dx is equal to now
here on the right hand side we're going
to apply the chain rule the derivative
of the cosine of something with respect
to that something is going to be equal
to negative sine negative sine of that
something so negative sine of 5x minus
3y and we have to multiply that by the
derivative of that something with
respect to X so what's the derivative of
the something with respect to X well the
derivative of 5x with respect to X is
just equal to 5 and the derivative of
negative 3 y with respect to X is just
negative 3 times dy/dx the negative 3
times the derivative of Y with respect
to X and now we just need to solve for
dy/dx as you can see with some of these
implicit differentiation problems this
is the hard part and actually let me
make that dy/dx the same color so that
we can keep track of it easier so this
is going to be dy/dx and then I can
close the parentheses so how can we do
it it's just going to be a little bit of
algebra to work through well we can
distribute the sine of 5x minus 3y so
let me rewrite everything we get dy
whoops I'm going to do that into the
yellow color we get dy/dx is equal to
you distribute the negative sine of 5x
minus 3y you get so let me make sure we
know what we're doing it's going to be
we're going to distribute that and we're
going to distribute that you're going to
5 times all of this so you're going to
have negative this 5 times the sine sine
of 5x minus 3y and then you're going to
have the negative times a negative those
are going to
you end up with a positive and so you're
getting up with plus plus three times
the sign three times the sine of 5x
minus 3y dy DX dy DX D Y DX now what we
can do is subtract three sine of 5x
minus 3y from both sides so just to be
clear this is essentially a 1 dy/dx so
if we subtract this from both sides we
are left with so on the left hand side
we're going to have a 1 dy DX and we're
going to subtract from that 3 sine of 5x
minus 3y dy DX's you're going to have 1
minus 3 I'll keep the color for the 3
for fun 3 sine of 5x minus 3y dy DX's on
the left hand side on the left hand side
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to well we subtracted this from
both sides so on the right hand side
this is going to go away so we're just
going to be left with a negative 5 sine
of sine of 5x minus 3y and we're in the
homestretch now to solve for dy/dx we
just have to divide both sides of the
equation by this and we are left with
dy/dx is equal to this thing negative 5
times the sine of sine of 5x minus 3y
all of that over 1 minus 3 3 sine sine
of 5x minus 3y and we are done